مشتعله تبقى عده محاور بين الجيشين الروسي
والاوكراني لاسيما عند نقاط التماسي
الاساسيه التطور الابرز في الجبهه يدور
عند ضفاف نهر النيبر
فيسك قالت القوات الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت
سته مسيرات ايرانيه الصنع
وشهدت مدينه زابوروشيا التي تقع تحت سيطره
اوكرانيا عده انفجارات في الساعات الماضيه
في وقت ما زالت محطه
تحت السيطره الروسيه وفي مناطق قريبه من
مدينه باخموت تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها
تشتبك بشكل مباشر مع الجيش الروسي في عده
نقاط وتتحدث عن تحقيق بعض التقدم الميداني
لا سيما عند سد كورديوموفوسكوي المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه نفت تحقيق اوكرانيا
اي تقدم وقالت ان الغرب لم يقم باي
استنتاج على خلفيه فشل هجوم القوات
الاوكرانيه المضاد كراماتورسك التي تعتبر
خط الهجوم الاوكراني باتجاه تعرضت لقصف
مكثف او قاع قتلى وجرحى وصفته كييف بهجوم
ارهابي
القوات الروسيه ردت على الاتهامات بنفس
استهداف البنيه التحتيه المدنيه واكدت ان
اهدافها تقتصر على البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه
ومن الامور اللافته ميدانيا استمرار تعرض
مدينه دانياتس لنيران الاوكرانيه فرغم
مرور قرابه تسع سنوات على اعلان انفصاليين
موالين لروسيا السيطره عليها لا تزال
المدينه غير امنه بالكامل
[موسيقى]